this year is the warmest on record and
with ocean temperatures reaching
dangerously high levels a major coral
bleaching event is predicted to hit the
Great Barrier Reef it's a race against
time to document these reefs before
climate change alters conditions here
the XL Catlin Seaview survey uses
cameras to take high numbers of 360
degree photographs of the bottom of the
sea
effectively mapping the seafloor like
Google Streetview Maps land with this
technology scientists are able to
establish a baseline for the coral reefs
so that after a bleaching event they can
figure out how much was actually lost
it's part of the largest visual
stocktake of corals on the planet ever
done
and after today's dodds I'm actually
feeling hopeful
the reefs here are thriving but then I
learned my optimism may be misplaced Oh
has footage from other reefs around the
world and he says what's happening there
will eventually happen here too
now this is largely a healthy reef right
now if you look at a reef that's under
stress like this one here
and there's bleaching all over the place
right that's what all these white
patches are that's right looks like it's
snowed underwater so some of that might
recover if it gets cooler sooner but a
lot of that will die either directly or
it'll die of starvation or disease so if
you look at look at the healthy reef on
the left-hand side with reefs that have
now start to bleach like the one on the
right and we're talking and Wow Wow
that's only a couple of months of it
being under that stress it is it's
surprising to see how quickly it happens
that is shocking the first time people
saw you know a mass bleaching event was
in the early 1980s and never before then
but in 1998 we had the first global
event but then you go to 2010 and
happens again 2015 2016 and it's
happening again and all that while it
appears that the interval between these
events is shortening and their intensity
is increasing we're now in the third
global mass bleaching event this year we
had very warm conditions coming into the
summer plus a strong El Nino and that
then pushed sea temperatures you know
right to the limit over most of the red